this video is sponsored by raycon you
know what
you know what sucks bullying
childhood and adolescence can be hard
enough as ears and no one deserves other
[ __ ] kids making their life
even harder than he is whether it be
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of you
getting ridiculed for the stuff you love
or god forbid
being called grant it's just not a
pleasant thing
according to stopbullying.gov 20 of
people aged 12 to 18 have experienced
bullying in america bullying affects all
youths and
its effects can be felt till adulthood
because you know what
that [ __ ] stays with you it's an awful
experience and
no kid ever deserves to be bullied
so with that in mind who the [ __ ]
actually wants to be
[Music]
don't toy with me nagatorio is one of
the most popular anime this season
if you've been hanging around the weeb
space recently you've probably seen this
place floating around
perhaps you've seen it as a screenshot
while scrolling down in your timeline or
near the top anime being watched
you've seen it as someone's profile
picture if it's not already your profile
picture i feel like nagatori is that one
show where people seem to have more of
an opinion about the people watching
nagatoro than nagatoro
itself in between her face being the
topical waifu profile picture of the
month and people losing their minds at
one of the subtitles using some word
that conveys nagatori's feeling of
mistrust towards another party or
something
it kind of feels like publicly liking
the show is the equivalent of being that
guy who turns up at an anime convention
wearing an ahegao hoodie using words
like
pogbas in a normal sentence like that's
a socially acceptable thing people do in
a functioning society but why are so
many people getting so riled up about
nagatori this season and what is it
about the girls teasing a flustered
classmate that seems to be becoming the
trends nowadays
are those of us watching this doing so
just because they have some masochism
complex where they want some anime girl
to step on them and call them trash
yes well that's what i'm here to find
out because surely there's more to this
than meets the eye right
so what's this all about i will now
begin the plot synopsis of don't toy
with me nagatoro don't toy with me
nagatoro follows this girl nagatoro
as she toys with her senpai
that concludes the plot synopsis of
don't toy with me nagatora this is the
latest show on a new trend that's
popping up called
[ __ ] smug girl mentally abused a
senior classmate for the amusement of
weebs worldwide
or i mean i guess we could just call it
the teasing genre and most of these
shows are just
exactly that normally it follows an
unlikely duo between a talking anime
profile picture and her
the shows takes us through various
situations where the girl playfully
teases her classmate of interest like
they are still on the school playground
except this time those girls that
bullied you as a kid are just secretly
doing so because they like you
and not because they're just [ __ ] who
picked on an easy target like that one
time you got shamed in front of everyone
just
because you liked anime oh man this got
pretty real the biggest difference
though right off the bat between this
and other shows like teasing master
takagi-san and uzaki-chan is that man
doesn't hold back like okay our main boy
is a beta with a capital b
the man has a spine of a [ __ ]
jellyfish and nagatora isn't afraid to
remind him of that
one bit in episode 1 she bullies him
insults him
makes him cry this ain't just your
average teasing this is for long mind
break cia interrogation
psychological warfare just to let this
guy know that he has small pp energy i
was honestly taken aback at how hard she
went initially there wasn't anything
playful about it it was just full-on
mean-spirited
there were some moments that made me so
uncomfortable for the guy that i
actually think i physically took cringe
damage
thankfully that was just episode 1
though and as the series goes on it
transitions to something far less
mean-spirited and more just playful
teasing but this start
certainly doesn't help to diminish the
image people have this show
and the people who watch it see there's
just something about the setup and
dynamics of the main leads that makes it
feel like everyone knows who this series
is targeted towards and what the main
appeal is
and that was definitely evident when
i've read ahead in the manga because
i see this art i see the premise and i
see these
beautifully smug faces that perfectly
catch the eye and i remember immediately
thinking one
[Music]
oh this guy's definitely drawn porn
which unsurprisingly if you look further
into it
oh he has and look i know we're not
allowed to say that this anime girl gets
people horny anymore without the risk of
getting arrested by the twitter police
but i think a massive part of the
initial appeal for anyone who's um
partaken in the consumption of artistic
drawings of the culture of nature
is that this just radiates the same
energy as a lot of dojinshi's you've
probably seen
and i feel like there are a bunch of
shows that air nowadays that radiate
that same energy
i can't put my finger on exactly what
this is because it's not simple to say
hey
this is just like every other edgy fan
service show cause
it's not but if i had to put into words
it takes a very specific skill set to be
able to create some of the mischievous
facial expressions you see
nagatoro make you see some of the most
well-known dojinshi artists have
a certain talent at making unique and
extreme
facial expressions to complement some of
the more intense
moments of their dojins let's just say
there are some
very memorable faces out there and
sometimes you see that same energy
radiating from the art and facial
expressions even if the situations
aren't exactly the same as what you'd
find in that other genre i mean look at
this perfectly smug
face look at these nude alarms it's like
that [ __ ] from itadaki seiki had a
tan's baby with a ball of cup ramen
like the exact moment that he confirmed
it for me was during the beach chapter
where of course all the girls show up in
swimsuits
alright okay nothing too unusual here
just a normal beach episode and then
nagatoro shows up and i'm just like wait
a minute
are those tan lines
oh this [ __ ] knows exactly what
he's doing i mean come on just look at
this
the man even broke the cardinal sin and
gave nagatoro both flesh fangs and
actual fangs
i don't know if he's trying to start a
civil war or stop one but he ain't
losing either way
combine this with the teasing the almost
masochistic dynamic at times shared
between the two main leads and this
is very very reminiscent to the dynamics
in certain other places and because of
that i can kind of see why so many of
the crowd that
partakes in the consumption of artistic
drawings of the culture nature seemed to
be the ones that were reading nagatoro
and other works similar to it
you can almost see the invisible tags of
culture on the episodes even if compared
to other ecchi manga and anime out there
right now
this one's actually quite tame in
comparison from a fan service
perspective
you know with all this context in mind
it kind of feels like
i can't don't say it you know it kind of
feels like god i know what you're
thinking don't [ __ ] say it
it kind of feels like having that bloody
little sister hentai dynamic without
having to morally worry about the incest
tag oh for [ __ ] sake
and i feel like this is the main reason
why nagatora and the shows like it
have the image and reputation that they
do if you just watch the first episode
see
the crowd circling in know where the
artist came from you're probably like
alright
i know exactly who and what this is for
it's the aigow hoodie wing crowd
probably has an anime profile picture
definitely rogers hentai maybe it's that
one guy who thinks shouting out discord
memes in public is funny
even if they weren't even funny on
discord but reading further into the
manga there's something that just gets
kind of drowned out in the general
discussion that i haven't seen many
people mention
yo this is awesome as [ __ ] that's right
this nagatoro
the same miss gonna cry piss your pants
i'll step on your peepee nice to meet
you ma'am your son calls me mommy too
nagatoro
is wholesome and i'm not just talking
about the obvious well you know she's
really mean to him but secretly she
really likes
even if that is somewhat true but there
is genuine character and relationship
development between the two
the biggest draw that kept me watching
the next episode that kept me reading
the next chapter of the manga
wasn't to see what culture tag we'd be
adding next but because in between the
teasing and the bullying out of nowhere
the show will just slap this really
heartwarming moment you weren't
expecting that would just make you go
god damn that was adorable as [ __ ] and
also since it starts off being a very
episodic virgin bullying of the week
kind of show
i was honestly surprised when the manga
started to introduce story arcs with an
actual reoccurring plotline which is
when i actually started to get properly
hooked into the manga
recently we've even been finding out a
bit more about nagatora and while
there's no dramatic dark backstory what
it does do is give opportunities for our
main boy semper
wait what the [ __ ] is his actual name
are you [ __ ] kidding me what it does
do is give opportunities for our main
boy to affect nagatoro and vice versa
honestly my favorite part of the manga
is seeing how the both of them slowly
change each other in a positive way
by hanging around nagatoro naoto
gradually gains confidence in himself
not only in his social situations but
his talents as well and despite what she
may appear like on the surface
the same happens for nagatoro seeing the
both of them playing off one another and
motivating each other to change for the
better might not be the most original
thing i've ever seen
but god damn if isn't wholesome as hell
i was surprised that genuine character
development was happening in front of me
that before i knew it
i was invested i don't know there's just
something about an unlikely duo helping
one another and possibly developing
feelings for each other that i just have
a soft spot for okay
look i love me some straightforward
romantic wholesomeness like horimia but
sometimes i just need a little bit of
that tension you gotta tickle the balls
just a little bit so i need a little bit
of that spice like with
nope i'm just not gonna go there anymore
unfortunately pera beta male afraid of
his own shadow with a smug tinder
who doesn't know how to come to terms
with their own feelings and what this
means is of course that it takes
[ __ ] forever for any meaningful
development to happen within their
relationship
normally i'm against anime relationships
that progress at a slower pace than
hawking radiation but you know what
i'm here for it i get it i'll just live
off that high of seeing that one
blushing wholesome moment in between
months of getting blue balls just oh
god please just don't be teasing my
heart and please give them a happy
ending
you know i think i finally get the
teasing genre
these anime are basically just like
edging
but for the soul god i hate the way my
mind works sometimes
in conclusion despite how the series
starts off nagatoro is a genuinely
wholesome story about two unlikely
characters affecting each other for the
better yes
it may at first remind you of a lot of
dojins you've seen and it may have some
fan service
element but this isn't nearly as horny
as i thought it was going to be
and the further i got the more i just
wanted to see the two of them
be happy i started for the smug but i
stayed
for the smile
[Music]
so yes i like nagatoro
because of course i [ __ ] do i
initially came into this ready to brush
off as just the new hot
waifu profile picture of the month you
know what i'll get some easy memes and
views out of this
job done let's move on but i came out
this being like what other bully manga
are there out there
maybe i'll read this one or this one or
this one
that one looks good oh god have i woken
something inside myself
again you know what why am i even trying
to deny it anymore
i might as well just accept who i really
am and take my place
with the people i truly belong with
poggers
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you again to reikon for sponsoring
me today
look if you've been watching my stuff
for a while you know the deal once again
i am asking you for my recon support
you see raycon are back at it again
disrupting the entire electronics
industry by offering premium wireless
earbuds for about half the price of its
competitors they give six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth pairing more
bass and a more compact design for a
more comfortable noise isolating
fit raycon was co-founded by ray j and
celebrities like mike tyson and snoop
dogg are obsessed with them
they offer their wireless earbuds in a
range of fun colors and patterns with a
variety of fit options and no
dangly wires or stems and don't forget
that raycon also have a 45 day free
return policy honestly i've been using
my rakons
every day for the last month or so
because i've recently just picked up my
japanese lessons again
and i've been using them to listen to
half an hour to an hour's worth of
japanese lessons
every single day it's been really useful
to be able to listen to japanese lessons
wherever i am even if i'm on the go on
the train or something
i just hope i don't look like a
psychopath to strangers to just mumbling
japanese to myself when i'm in public
thank god everyone's wearing a mask so
what are you waiting for
click the link in the description or go
to biorecon.com for 15
off your order that's by raycon.com for
15 percent
off look i swear to god i did not go
into nagatoro thinking that i was going
to like it
at all i just really ended up liking it
okay
oh god damn it god i don't know
sometimes i just can't escape who i am
i'm sorry i'm sorry okay i'm just a
slave to the smug face okay
i'm a simple guy anyway i'll probably
just leave it at that today
i don't really have any updates to tell
you guys japan's back in an emergency
state so
i'm going to be inside for a lot once
more
i just hope wherever you are in the
world the situation
is improving so that's all from me
i've been giggling and i will see you
all next time
and you know what i hope you have a
wonderful day